this cat better watch out and the only
thing more badass than guns is kittens
its episode 33 of IMG this is every way
Mario can die on one page and this is a
hadouken manicure but could you grab me
some peanut butter
oh but watch out for the honey shaving
cream but the best type of spill cat
face look how happy it made this guy
what uh oh banana dog better than a
heart but and spot the difference
here's Lady Gaga drinking tea some guys
really really like this and thus hot
girls drinking tea tumbler calm enjoy
remember the big bad wolf well here's
what he should have done do you guys
accept Batman and Joker money look look
how well I throw a hammer oh the great
outdoors with the body and the great
outdoors with a face but let's get
trickier with gifts some are hypnotizing
we patriotic and others use rapidly
reversing colors to perpetually move
towards you this one too if you've got
red cyan 3d glasses take a look at these
worms just do it someone just did it
but now let's lay down with stuffed
animal versions of ourselves and enjoy
two montages in one video
[Music]
photobombs are great but this one is
currently my favorite hi let's hold
hands I want to keep you safe oh just
kidding go in for the dunk
we got a booger there and you know what
lots of guys get caught staring John
Kerry even Obama sometimes it's sneaky
sometimes it's surprising and sometimes
it's just judgmental on facebook.com
slash a Vsauce gaming Anton showed me
that spongebob is made out of sadness
Stephanie introduced a keyboard shaped
waffle maker and Krishna showed us a dog
that can make things float and terrify
people now it's time to watch loot on
our other channel Vsauce - Vsauce - is
just like Vsauce except we get to be a
little bit more specific over there now
if you're not subscribed to us because
you don't have a youtube account make
today be the first day of the rest of
your life create a YouTube account it's
free and it feels wonderful with an
account you can subscribe to us and know
exactly when we put new stuff out and
you can favorite our videos so you never
lose that link to a flash game and dog
that you don't want to lose if you don't
have a youtube account yet and you
create your first one today and
subscribe to us let us know in the
comments below so that we can all thank
you for making the world a better place
and tell you personally as always
thanks for watching
you